so welcome to the 100th of these long
now seminars I've recognized many
familiar faces so I know many of you
have been steady supporters of the
foundation and attendees of the seminar
series and in fact the foundation is now
kind of in commemoration of this hundred
thing we will be publishing actually a
book also available as an e-book which
is Stuart's
summaries of all the seminars which does
of you who are on his mailing list know
that you know they're actually well
worth the read for the ones you missed
and this was actually the book was
designed by Alice Rogers is one of our
members and that will be available for
the longer from the long now foundation
on the website Larry has been hacking
some of our longest term in engineered
objects which is law and government for
a long time I'm sure you all know who he
is
which is why you're here so without
further introduction let me bring in
Larry Lessig
thank you
so it's wonderful to be here this is got
to be the coolest group to be able to
present ideas to and so I'm grateful to
have a chance to do it I had a little
bit of a fight with the organizers about
the title I go for poetic so I wanted
this to be the title Republic lost and
they said to me well what the hell does
it mean and I said oh I'm sorry Republic
, lost that didn't help they insisted on
this much more you know engineering
appropriate title how money corrupts
Congress and a plan to stop and I
thought maybe I would you know just
subvert their objectives by going back
to my other title but no okay I'll stick
to the title I want to make it perfectly
clear here's what I'm gonna do I'm going
to first describe to you how money
corrupts Congress and then what I'm
going to do is I'm going to give you a
plan to stop it is that clear
okay so here's the how we got to begin
by a little bit of brainwashing to get
you to think about this in the way I
want you to think about this and I'm
going to do this through a series of
stories the first is familiar to many of
you here because you were in the middle
of this fight with me it's fight around
the issue of copyright law IP I became
an activist in copyright law on October
27th 1998 when President Bill Clinton
signed into a law a statute honoring
this great American the Sonny Bono
copyright term extension Act a statute
which extended the term of existing
copyrights by 20 years now the question
that Congress was supposed to be asking
when it passed that statute was whether
it advanced the public good to extend
the term of an existing copyright by 20
years of course copyrights are important
for creating the incentives for people
to produce great new creative work but
the one thing we know about incentives
is that they are Pro spective not even
the United States Congress can get
George Gershwin to produce anything more
so it couldn't possibly make sense to
extend the term of an existing copyright
at least from the perspective of what
copyright law is about and so when we
challenge this statute and went to the
Supreme Court and got a whole bunch of
economists to sign a brief saying this
could make no sense we got this liberal
economist and I'm sorry that's Milton
Friedman right-wing Nobel Prize winning
economist to sign the brief but he said
he would only sign the brief of the word
no-brainer was in the brief so obvious
was it that you couldn't advance the
public good by extending the term of an
existing copyright but apparently there
were no brains in this place when
Congress unanimously extended the term
of existing copyrights what there was
was a whole bunch of money from
interests that benefited from having
their special monopoly extended the
look good be damned and while we're on
the IP story let's talk about another
example I'm sure a certain terror came
across many of you today as you saw on
your Wikipedia site then we're gonna
lose Wikipedia and a whole bunch of
other fantastic sites tomorrow in the
name of fighting for Internet freedom a
fight against PIPA and SOPA and whatever
else you want to call out they're going
on in the universe from Congress
statutes which Congress are enacting or
trying to enact or dancing around about
whether they're going to enact so that
more campaign money comes in dancing and
singing about trying to advance the
interest they have in continuing to
protect intellectual property no what is
this statute about well here is sopa
sopa has a very clear objective its
objective is to promote prosperity
creativity entrepreneurship and
innovation by combating the theft of us
property and for other purposes and it
does this by giving federal courts the
power to shut down websites that engage
in enable or facilitate copyright
infringement now I get the first one
those who engage in copyright
infringement but just think about those
sites that enable or facilitate
copyright infringement we could call
those sites the Internet
so here's the statute to give federal
judges the powers to shut down the
internet how do they actually go about
this basically somebody comes in and ask
them says here's a site we believe is
engaging in this illegal criminal
activity we want you to shut it down
no hearing no need to give any notice no
need to actually prove beyond just the
allegation in the context of somebody
having a chance to respond
that leads some people to say isn't that
a prior restraint the sort of thing that
the Constitution was originally designed
to avoid in the First Amendment Lawrence
tribe at Harvard said yep that's exactly
what it is a prior restraint which is
why he is leading a bunch of law
professors against this statute what
about the First Amendment people say
well I hid the First Amendment in the
context of copyright when I argued the
case in the Supreme Court trying to
limit the term of the copyright term
extension Act justice O'Connor after I
raised the First Amendment argument
responded to me like this she said if
you say that the copyright Clause is not
violated I don't think there are
examples where this Court has then
resorted to First Amendment analysis to
invalidate the same Act
the famous copyright exception to the
First Amendment which of course reigns
in all sorts of context in our
jurisprudence all of these factors
together should get us to recognize this
is a pretty extraordinary law and it's
led many people to say whether it
advances innovation it's also going to
kill a whole bunch of innovation because
of the uncertainty and insecurity that
it's adding into the internet so sure
this statute was proposed to combat
theft of us property but if these people
are right it's not really a statute
about any of those things so what is it
a statute about and I remind you now of
the other purposes I don't know what the
statutes about here's what I do know map
light fantastic organization in Berkeley
which tracks the relationship between
money and politics has this to say about
this statute if you support this statute
you get 13 times as much money in
campaign contributions from those
support this statute as if you oppose
its there is another IP example IP 3
let's call this another statue just
introduced last month this is the
research works Act a statute introduced
bipartisan statute by carolyn maloney a
Democrat from New York and Daryl eyes as
a Republican from California his statute
was inspired by a practice than NIH
adopted of requiring that
government-funded research
government-funded research let's just be
clear government funded research be
available twelve months after its
published to be downloaded for free for
free you know in the very weird sense of
free right we paid for this research
right that's the whole point
government-funded research here's the
way it works we the people take our
money and give it to the governments the
government then gives it to the NIH the
NIH then buys the research and that's
the sense in which we get this for free
when the NIH says we're going to turn it
over to the public after twelve months
for free that's the condition of taking
the money and publishing the research
now some publishers don't like this this
Dutch publisher Reed Elsevier they don't
like this they're really into the
business model of the market where they
have exploited the power that they have
in academic journals to raise the price
of academic journals over the past
period of time much higher than
inflation by far they enjoy that market
and that market doesn't do too well when
the government mandates that you must
handout after 12 months these articles
for free so they went to their friends
mr. Issa and MS Maloney in Congress
that's Maloney not baloney that's
Maloney in Congress and they got them to
introduce this bill and this bill bans
the NIH from acquiring this policy and
it bans any government agency from
conditioning giving money on Mickey
the work publicly available it bans open
access why does it ban open access well
miss Maloney wrote a piece on blog in
response to a letter so that it saves
American jobs on the well-known economic
theory that if you tax people twice you
get more jobs right because we're taxing
people once to raise the money to pay
for the research and now we're taxing
them again to get access to it so double
taxation increases jobs or here's
another great argument to advance the
public interest in the important
peer-review publishing system
congressman peer review is done for free
people for free peer review articles you
don't need money to cover the peer
review cost that's what the public
library of science here in San Francisco
has demonstrated again and again so what
explains this law banning us from
getting for free what we pay for I don't
know I don't have a clue
I don't begin to understand it but
here's what map light tells me you got
6.1 times the amount of money if you
support this bill as if you oppose this
bill and indeed congresswoman Maloney
has gotten 40% of the contributions from
Elsevier and Elsevier executives 40% of
their contributions have gone to her
where here's another example another IP
example but not intellectual property
let's talk about broadband for a second
so just in case you are wondering
broadband in America sucks it's a
technical term but that's the fact it
sucks
here we are an advertised download
speeds but any number of these OECD
graphs we'd be about the same like way
down there with Spain right with Spain
alright so the question we have in our
future is whether this is a picture of
broadband for us or whether this is the
picture of broadband for us right and
there are lots of governments struggling
with this question including state
governments so the state of North
Carolina the worst broadband state in
the country bizarrely I don't understand
it but that's the fact the worst in the
three had a whole bunch of cities
especially in the Research Triangle
decide what they wanted to try to do was
to launch community broadband where the
cities would help support the building
of broadband infrastructure so that the
21st century could actually come to
North Carolina and the project proved to
be enormous ly successful so here's a
graph a little bit hard to understand
but here's let me just make it simple
here's the picture these numbers in the
box represent upload and download speeds
for these community broadband sites the
size of the bubble is the price okay so
if you paid $85 under this vibrant
system you got fifty five megabits
upstream and fifty five megabits
downstream perfectly symmetrical and all
these other community ones are way up
there in price performance and all the
ones at the bottom are the time warner
AT&T dsl provisions okay so experiments
in community innovation proved to be
brilliantly successful in bringing fast
broadband to North Carolina
then the legislators in North Carolina
saw this problem and decided they were
going to deal with it through
House bill h 129 in North Carolina
passed last year and signed into law by
a Democratic governor a blow that makes
community broadband a sexually banned in
North Carolina just one more example of
state law making that is systematically
disabling local communities from doing
something about the duopoly that is
denying America broadband now why would
they do that heck if I know what I know
though is that there's endless campaign
money that went into this fight to get
them to do this insane public policy
step or here's another example look at
tax code the Wall Street Journal last
year was puzzled at the number of
temporary tax provisions in our tax code
these temporary tax provisions which
expire requiring an extender leading to
what the Wall Street Journal called
extend
mania and there it is it's kind of
maniacal the way it kind of goes up like
that what explains the Wall Street
Journal this says this explosion and
extenders well it turns out Ronald
Reagan gave us our first temporary tax
provision and it was a good idea 1981 in
The Temper in the tax reform act package
of 1981 there's the research and
development tax credit and when this was
proposed Democrats said it would never
work Republicans said of course it would
work they struck a deal they said they
would make it temporary for the purpose
of testing it and after a period of time
they asked the question did it work they
asked economists on both sides and
economists on both side says it did work
all of Hahnemann's agreed it was a
really fantastic tax credit idea it
spurred a kind of investment that
wouldn't otherwise have been spurred and
therefore it made sense to be part of
our tax code absolutely
but here's the puzzle it is to this day
temporary it's a temporary part of our
tax code why is that well Rebekkah kai
star in this article in the georgia law
review has her theory she says the
principle recipients of the research
credit are large US manufacturing
corporations these business entities are
more than willing to invest in lobbying
activities and campaign donations to
ensure continuance of this large tax
savings the Institute for Policy
innovation tax bites had a little bit
more direct way of putting it this cycle
has repeated for years Congress allows
the credit to lapse until another short
extension is given proceeded of course
by a series of fundraisers and speeches
about the importance of nurturing
innovation Congress essentially uses
this cycle to raise money for
re-election promising industry more
predictability the next time around the
point of recognises this dynamic is
central to the way Washington
increasingly works we architect our tax
policy at least in part to make it
easier to raise campaign funds not
revenue for the Treasury but revenue for
the
campaign Treasuries and it's not just
tax policy when Al Gore was vice
president he had an idea his team had an
idea to deregulate a significant chunk
of the communications infrastructure to
support broadband development
deregulation way below even network
neutrality requirements his team took
the idea to the hill and the guy who was
running the idea told me the response
from the hill was this they said hell no
if we deregulate these guys how are we
going to raise money from them so we tax
in part to raise campaign funds we
regulate in part to raise campaign funds
campaign funds at the core of these
crucial fiscal decisions that our
government makes or one other very
familiar example thing about Wall Street
of course we just seen this collapse
which brought down an economy what is
responsible for this collapse well Simon
Johnson and James quack described in
this book 13 bankers
it's this perverse mix of both two
little governments and too much
government too little government in the
form of deregulation the 1990s saw all
sorts of financial innovations what we
call derivatives but because of a mania
around deregulation these innovations
were effectively invisible to the
marketplace the kind of regulations that
traditionally applied to stocks and
bonds requiring transparency and that
they're traded on a public exchange and
that anti-fraud requirements those
regulations didn't attach to derivatives
because lawmakers changed the rules to
guarantee they wouldn't attached to
derivatives so as my colleague Frank
partner had calculated in 1980 he said
ninety-eight percent of the assets
traded in our economy were traded in
these public exchanges through these
transparent requirements that had
anti-fraud obligations attached to the
trades but by 2008 90% of the assets
traded in this market were traded
invisibly without any
public trading obligation or
transparency obligation not even an
obligation to live up to anti-fraud
requirements a shadow banking market
emerged and because nobody knew what was
out there it effectively encouraged the
bubble which of course when it burst
brought down this economy now but that
wasn't alone enough according to quack
and Johnson in addition to too little
government there was too much government
throughout the 1990s the government gave
a clear beacon signal to Wall Street
that there was an effective government
guarantee when this bubble burst the
government guarantee in the form of a
bailout on the other side producing what
is certainly the dumbest form of
socialism in the history of man we
socialized the risk but privatize the
benefit they got the upside we got the
downside now I know this is not an
audience of lawyers so I apologize for
this technical legal term but this is an
insanely stupid way to regulate a
financial system and why did we do it
like that
now that stupidity was all before 2008
it can't begin to compete with the
stupidity after 2008 because after 2008
after we have had the worst crisis since
the depression after we've seen this
crisis destroy an economy our Congress
essentially adds insult to injury here
because after this damage has been done
after people independent of Wall Street
who analyzed Wall Street attributed the
damage to the failure to regulate these
derivatives in an appropriate way people
on the left and people on the right
Judge Richard Posner conservative
federal judge from the Seventh Circuit
in two books attributed strip Ute sent
directly to this failure to regulate
after the Dean of deregulation alan
greenspan confessed in testimony to
Congress that it was a mistake he made
to believe that the banks would be
acting in the public interest as opposed
to their private interests after all of
the
still Wall Street had the power to
blackmail our government Democrats and
Republicans alike to basically get a
get-out-of-jail-free card and to leave
the instability that led to this
collapse still in place if the banks
were too big to fail before 2008 they
are only to bigger to fail after 2008
now what is it that explains this
stupidity heck if I know but one thing I
know is that the explosion and campaign
cash from this financial sector was
unmatched anywhere in our economy and
indeed in 2010 the largest chunk of
contributions come from the financial
service sector and one final example
sure many of you when you saw Deepwater
Horizon images had this question that I
had a - which is how was it that we had
this extraordinary experimental drilling
technology that was permitted without
extensive environmental impact and risk
studies I mean after all where I come
from now that I can't say I come from
here anymore but I come from now we've
just gone through 9 years and 10,000
pages of environmental impact studies to
permit this green energy project to go
forward so how much analysis was done of
the Deepwater Horizon before it was
allowed to drill it's extraordinarily
deep drill the answer is 17 pages of
environmental impact analysis before
they were exempted from any further
environmental analysis obligations now
when Congress heard about this Congress
of course was shot of course it was
Congress that had required these
fast-track approval processes and that
leads us to ask the obvious question why
would they lead fast-track approval
process even with these experimental
technologies and the answer is heck if I
know this is the only thing we know for
certain is the endless cash into
campaigns that drove to precisely this
regulatory structure
list cache again now here's the point no
respectable liberal or libertarian or
conservative could defend these cases
each of them is an abomination from each
of these political philosophies so how
did they become part of our government
policy structure political scientists
actually are kind of uncertain they say
it's really complex to answer all of
this but here's the thing I'm quite
certain of I am quite certain you
believe you know all I have to do is
point to the money all I have to do is
point to the money and you believe you
know the root cause to this craziness
and my claim is number one it is because
of cases like this that Americans
believe quote money buys results in
Congress seventy five percent of
Americans believe money buys results in
Congress a little bit more Democrats and
Republicans but I guarantee you before
the Republicans took over it was just as
many Republicans as Democrats so whether
it's two-thirds or three-fourths here's
the one thing we all agree about money
buys results in Congress and that leads
to number two that belief erodes trust
in the institution so last year Gallup
found that 11 percent of Americans had
confidence in Congress things were
looking up this year that number was 12%
but then the New York Times reported
that actually it's actually 9 percent of
Americans who have confidence in
Congress 9 percent right but in some
contexts if in 1974 the federal
government had somehow done a survey of
the Soviet Union and found that 15
percent of Soviet citizens had
confidence in the Soviet government we
would have declared victory communism
was obviously dead the government had no
confidence of its people 15 percent but
we have 9 percent it is certainly the
case that there was more support for the
British crown in our government at the
time of the Revolution then there is
support for our Congress today
and that leaves number of three low
trust erodes participation Rock the Vote
extraordinary organization that turned
out the largest number of young voters
in the last election arguably actually
absolutely certain that they produced
the election of Barack Obama found that
in 2010 significant number of their
people we're not going to turn out and
vote so they asked them why the number
one reason by far two-to-one over the
second-highest reason was quote no
matter who wins corporate interests will
still have too much power and prevent
real change and it's not just kids
the vast majority who could have voted
in the last election did not vote in
part because of this belief that's point
one money here erodes trust now you
might ask well is that all it does is it
the only thing it does I mean if it's
all that it does is it Road trust maybe
we're just wrong maybe we shouldn't
worry about it because you know it's
actually not doing any harm there's no
reason to worry that it maybe is
screwing things up so does it do
something then other than just erode
trust what does money actually do here
well it turns out we can think about
this in two ways what does it do to the
substance of what Congress does and then
what does it do to Congress's agenda and
about the substance that it actually is
among political scientists a little bit
of a controversy I was on a radio show
with Bradley Smith former head of the
Federal Elections Commission and he
uttered this on the radio show the
evidence is pretty overwhelming that the
money does not play much of a role in
what goes on in terms of legislative
voting patterns and legislative behavior
the consensus about that among people
who have studied it is roughly the same
as the consensus among scientists that
global warming is taking place now to be
clear Bradley Smith is not a global
warming skeptic he is a corruption
skeptic I was so astonished by this I
had to tweet it at the time they get a
lot of trouble for my hashtag but that
just means Bradley Smith that's what
that stands for
so what is the evidence here that
results actually are driven by the money
well it turns out there's an increasing
amount of statistical work that's trying
to demonstrate statistically and
powerfully the connection between
contributions and influence but I find
the most compelling is this work by
Martin gilens from Princeton who looked
at seventeen hundred and eighty-one
public opinion surveys and these public
opinion surveys tracked the attitudes of
people and of course because they were
well done surveys you could see the
attitudes of people as a function of
whether you were the rich or the rest of
us and what guidelines then did is he
looked at 887 of these surveys where
what the top group 10 percent of us
wanted was different from what the rest
of us ninety percent of us wanted and he
asked the question when 10 percent want
to go left and 90 percent want to go
right which way does Congress go and
this what he found
I find that when Americans with
different income levels differ in their
policy preferences actual policy
outcomes strongly reflect the
preferences of the most affluent
but they're virtually no relationship to
the Preferences of the poor or middle
income Americans a vast discrepancy
exists between what our Congress would
be doing if our Congress were following
what the people wanted and what our
Congress does given our Congress follows
what the most affluent want now you
could say well the most affluent are
just the smartest the most educated and
as a professor I'd love to believe that
if it were true but it turns out sad to
confess the most affluent are not the
best educated they're not the wisest
this is not government doing wise public
policy choices this is government
following what the richest in our
society wants and guess what they are
also the people giving the most to the
campaign's so that's substance what
about agenda here the arguments a little
bit easier and so this claim that
doesn't affect legislative behavior is
just absolutely false it's a way to see
it if I ask you what was the number one
issue in the first four months of 2011
that Congress spent its time dealing
with you know in the middle of two wars
at that
huge unemployment problem we had a
budget crisis coming up there still was
a lot to do in health care so what was
the number one issue that they spun
their wheels dealing with the answer is
the bank swipe fee controversy the bank
swipe fee controversy dominated the
Congressional agenda now what was that
controversy you might have missed it I
know you were busy the first four months
of last year the bank's five-feet
controversy is the question whether when
you swipe your debit cards banks get to
charge more or retailers get to pay less
that's the controversy all right a lot
of money on the table swipe fees are an
extraordinarily lucrative industry for
some and they spent an enormous amount
of time dealing with this issue because
as this Huffington Post piece put it the
clock never takes down to zero in
Washington one years laws the next
year's repeal target politicians
showered with cash from card companies
and giant retailers alike have been
moving back and forth between camps paid
handsomely for their shifting
allegiances and then again it dawns on
you shocked you should be if you have
any faith in our system that the very
agenda Congress sets the things they
work on versus things they don't work on
is driven as well by the desire to raise
money so why don't we address the
unemployment issue turns out doesn't pay
so well in campaign fundraising to
address unemployment ok so this is point
to money distorts what our Congress does
it distorts the issues they work on and
it distorts the results relative to the
baseline of what the results would be if
in fact they were following what we the
people wanted but is it corruption after
all the Supreme Court in a decision that
will become a toddler in just 2 days
the Citizens United decision concluded
that independent expenditures but we now
know as super PAC type expenditures
including those made by corporations do
not give rise to corruption or the
appearance of corruption so if they
don't give rise to the appearance of
corruption is what I've got
here corruption because I have not said
anybody is guilty of bribery I have not
said anybody made any quid pro quo I've
not said anybody has violated any
federal law so have I described
corruption well with all due respect to
the Supreme Court what the Supreme Court
says here is totally wrong
and we have very precise measures in the
law and I can show you exactly what
totally wrong is but it is totally wrong
is about this much wrong this is plainly
corruption and I have my black board
here to prove it plainly corruption and
here's how you can see it the framers of
our constitution gave us what they
called a republic but what they meant by
a republic it was a representative
democracy and what they meant by a
representative democracy as Federalist
52 describes is a democracy where
there'd be a branch of government which
ought to be quote dependent upon the
people alone so here's the model of
government we have the people we have
the government I do my own slides it's
really cool the way that bounces like
that right so people governments it's
kind of marionette relationship
dependency is clear and exclusive here's
the problem Congress has evolved a
different dependence it's not just
dependent upon the people it's
increasingly dependent upon the funders
as members spend between 30 and 70% of
their time raising money to get back to
Congress or to get their party back into
power they develop a sixth sense a
constant awareness about how what they
might do will affect their ability to
raise money they become in the words of
the x-files
shape shifters constantly adjusting
themselves in light of what they know
will raise money not an issue one to ten
but on issue 11 to 2444 Leslie Byrne a
Democrat from Virginia describes that
when she went to Congress she was told
by a colleague quote always lean to the
green and then to clarify she went on he
was not an environmentalist
now the point is this is a dependence
too and it is a different and
conflicting dependence from a dependence
upon the people alone because surprise
surprise the funders turn out not to be
the people point to six percent of
Americans give more than $200 in a
congressional campaign point zero five
percent of Americans max out in a
congressional campaign point zero one
percent one out of a thousand Americans
give more than ten thousand dollars to
all candidates in a congressional cycle
so the Occupy Wall Street people are so
proud of the we are their 99 percent bad
marketing right we're either the ninety
nine point seven four percent or the
99.95% of the ninety nine point nine
nine percent who don't have the power
that the point two six or point zero
five or point zero one percent have
because they are funding the campaigns
now this is absolutely clear this is
corruption it is not corruption yeah you
should clap for that that's really
important let the Supreme Court hear it
is not the corruption of money secreted
in brown paper bags handed out to
members of Congress you know they used
to be safes in the offices of Congress
safes you think why would they pay
members of Congress in cash and it
turned out they didn't
it's just members found cash on their
desk and they needed a safe place to
keep it so they had saves that doesn't
happen anymore Congress in that sense is
as clean as it has ever been and it is
very very clean it is not an institution
filled with the likes of rob lukovitch
but even though it's not this is still a
corruption relative to the framers
baseline of a system dependent upon the
people alone they're not this is a
dependence corruption because they have
the wrong dependence it is corruption
because they follow the funders at least
in places where the funders conflict
with what the people want
that my friends is how money corrupts
the wrong dependency distorts the word
and weakens the trust of the institution
that's how this institution gets bent so
what's a plan for doing something about
it a plan okay well let's step back
start with zero here recall the sacred
text there are a thousand hacking at the
branches of evil henry david thoreau
1846 on Walden there are a thousand
hacking at the branches of evil - one
who was striking at the roots let's call
that one a root Stryker I tried to
convince John Stewart of that he said no
no Batman would be better but okay put
it aside Rude Stryker one striking at
the root now here's the problem the
problem is not that we have an
institution filled with Liguria [ __ ]
the problem is the system not evil souls
and so the solution is not to lock up
all sorts of people in Congress some we
should Liguria vich we should but that's
not going to solve the problem we solve
the problem with a thorough vien insight
we solve the problem by stopping our
persistent pattern of hacking at all the
different branches of evil and spend a
cycle or two striking at the root
if the systemic problem here is that the
funders are not the people the systemic
solution is to find a way to make the
funders the people to give them away I
know that looks like one word I don't
mean to give Congress away I know a lot
of people would like to do that but I
mean give them a way to fund without
Faust without selling their souls and
therefore without alienating America
because America believes they've sold
their souls for a tiny bit of money and
the one way to do this and I think
increasingly the only way to do this is
finally as a people to commit firmly and
openly to the need for publicly funding
public elections
[Applause]
we have to replace a system of large
dollar funded campaigns with small
dollar funded campaigns and we can
follow the model of states that have
experimented like Arizona or Maine or
Connecticut to opt into systems where
candidates need to take small dollar
contributions only and through a variety
of different tricks those contributions
then get amplified so they can afford to
run winning campaigns never taking large
donations now there are many ways to do
this in my book Republic comma lost
really poetic right Republic comma lost
I described one that I call the grant
and Franklin project it looks something
like this you first have to stipulate
with me that every American contributes
at least contributes in quotes 50
dollars to the federal treasury not an
income tax necessarily but in some form
of taxes so under the proposal that I
have I say let's take that first $50 you
contribute and let's rebate it in the
form of democracy voucher and a
candidate can get this democracy voucher
from you you can give it to a candidate
or to any number of candidates if that
candidate agrees to number one fund his
or her campaign only with democracy
vouchers plus contributions limited to a
hundred dollars a citizen grants and
Franklin so you fund your campaigns with
small dollar contributions only and if
you don't allocate the money if somebody
doesn't allocate their voucher then we
can allocate it to the parties or in
states like California where most people
are not a member of parties that can go
into some democracy supporting entity
all right now $50 a voter is seven
billion dollars the total amount raised
in 2010 was 1.8 billion dollars so this
is three times the total amount raised
in 2010 not even counting the hundred
dollar contributions it is real money
that would make funding elections in
this small dollar way possible and
effective and make it possible for
candidates to opt into a world where
they didn't have to take the large
contributions to fund their campaign but
would it be enough to clean the system I
used to believe it would
two years ago I thought it would and
even after the Supreme Court decided
citizens united I was not yet convinced
that that would change the fact that
public funding alone would be enough but
I now believe that public funding alone
is not enough we've entered the age of
the super PAC not just the happy super
PACs but the very dark super PACs and
we've seen it that's Tony Soprano in
case you don't recognize okay so we
ventured this kind of super PAC dynamic
which actually political scientists have
not begun to model but which is
absolutely driving the way Washington
functions today heaven by who retired
from the United States and it described
this to me on a panel that I was sitting
with him on he said the biggest fear
that incumbents now have remember
incumbents the people who had no fear in
the past the people who are guaranteed
re-election who had all the money in the
world who had super poll numbers
incumbents were in power the biggest
fear incumbents now have is that 30 days
out from an election some super PACs
going to come in and drop a million
dollars in the district and so what is
the incumbents supposed to do because by
definition if that happens he can't turn
to his largest contributors they've
maxed out so who can he turn to the only
people he can turn to is super PACs on
his side but it's a little late to do
that at the last moment so what he's got
to do is buy super packed insurance in
advance so that if some bomb gets
dropped on your side against you you
have somebody who's willing to drop a
bomb against them so how do you buy
super PAC insurance well they don't have
many of those left anymore but if I
would have been an idea before but now
you buy your insurance the way you buy
any insurance you have to pay your
premium in advance how do you pay your
premium in advance well the super PAC
says things like we'd love to help you
senator but we can only support people
who support us at at least 80% according
to our charter so without even spending
$1 the super PACs are able to induce
congressmen and
to behave exactly how they want them to
behave so that if they get attacked they
have a reliable protection racket that
can step forward and answer on the other
side so the incumbents are no longer the
Barons the incumbents are the vassals
vassals to Barons who run these super
PACs radically shifting the dynamic of
power inside of Washington which means
here I think that we're gonna need much
more than just public funding what we're
going to need as well is an amendment to
the Constitution now I know a lot of
people are really anxious about this a
lot of people have really a lot of faith
in what our framers of our Constitution
did they of course they had no mistakes
at all so how could they have made a
mistake here and I just want to can you
know allay your concerns I've actually
done my own research and discovered that
there's a forgotten Amendment that the
framers actually did pass we just have
to get it re ratified it goes something
like this all that we need to do is to
reaffirm what they said 240 years ago
Congress shall have the power to limit
but not to ban independent expenditure
political expenditures within 90 days of
an election that amendment which says
you can't silence anybody nobody should
be silenced whether it's corporations or
foreigners or dolphins everybody should
be allowed to put their position out
there but Congress has to have the
ability to make sure that they can't so
dominate the process that everybody
wonders whether they're shape-shifting
now for the independent expenditures
just like their shape-shifting for the
contributions that amendment is an
essential part of the reform we need
what we need then is these two things
public funding and a limit on these
independent expenditures to produce what
we might imagine dream of as a
trustworthy Congress and if we had those
two if we had a world where small dollar
contributions were the only thing
driving campaigns then we all could
believe as we all want to believe that
when Congress does something idiotic
it's either because there's too many
Democrats or
because there are too many Republicans
but not because of the money because we
would have set up a condition where
Trust was possible because the thing
that leads us to mistrust would have
been removed if we can produce that
system all right now how would we get
there
because I don't think it's hard to see
the problem I don't even think it's hard
to describe a solution what's hard what
maybe impossibly hard here is to imagine
the political movement that brings that
solution about and the reason this is so
hard
is a reason suggested me by congressman
Jim Cooper Democrat from Tennessee man
who's been in Congress as long as all
but about 20 other members of Congress
and in describing how this institution
changed cooper said to me the problem
with Congress is that Congress Capitol
Hill has now become a quote farm League
for K Street K Street where all the
lobbyists work so what he means by that
is that members and staffers and
bureaucrats inside the beltway have an
increasingly common business model a
business model focused on their life
after government their life as lobbyists
Public Citizen calculated between 1998
and 2004 50% of senators left to become
lobbyists 42% of members of the House
and those numbers have only gone up
everybody inside of the system depends
upon the system surviving and if that's
true how could we ever imagine the
political movement that would change
this system and deny a significant
number of them their retirement plan
because they won't be million-dollar
lobbyists and so here's then the
challenge to find a way around this
cancer that has become our governments
in DC and the first step to doing this
is to recognize that political issues
are not just divided between left and
right in America that's not the most
important division the critical division
that is increasingly making its making
self known is the division between
inside and outside government yeah well
there's the outsider okay you guys we're
gonna join with that outsider in a
minute this is the key what we need to
do is to enable what we could call
outsider politics which means not some
top-down organized structure for taking
over the government but this grassroots
bottom-up structure not a politics field
with politicians but a politics filled
with people who swear off becoming
politicians but our citizens not a
professional politics but in amateur
politics in the sense of an amateur not
someone who's doing something for the
money but for the love of what they're
doing these are people are doing
something not for the power but for the
love of the nation not the kind of
read-only politics that governed
politics in the twenty century but
instead of kind of read/write politics
where people are active and engaged and
awoken a politics where the sovereign US
has is awake and can take the power back
that we need to fix the damage that
they've done that's outside our politics
now
this outsider politics needs to do two
incredibly different difficult things at
the same time number one it has to
figure out how to be cross partisan that
doesn't mean giving up the political
commitments of one side or another but
it means figuring out how to radically
different perspectives might be able to
agree not on a common end but a common
enemy and I think that's possible if
this cross partisan movement focuses not
on the substantive fights we might have
but on the rules of the game the
conditions within which the system
operates that leads us to believe that
it's a fair or trustworthy system or not
now both of these are extremely hard to
do extremely hard to be disciplined
about but either of these the cross
partisanship is difficult because always
it's the other side who's the enemy the
evil ones the right is the enemy or the
left is the enemy that's what gets us
going that's what makes this fun and
focus on rules is boring because the
passion is in the substance equality or
fighting for a just society or some
smaller attacks whatever you want to
fight for that's where it's exciting the
rules are not exciting except two rules
geek rule geeks like me but the point is
both of these kinds of commitments are
necessary because what we need here is
constitutional change to happen and in
our system constitutional change only
happens if three-quarters of the states
agree seventy-five percent of the states
have to line up between any such change
now we've seen the beginnings of such a
politics in the United States but I
think these beginnings have failed so
move on I think is the first kind of
rustling to this they launched in 1998
to bring sense to the insanity of a
system that was focusing impeachment on
a man who slept with his assistant and
quiet about it move on said are you
kidding this is the most important
problem let's send
the man and move on but quickly the
movement fell to become a movement on
the left not cross partisan anymore but
a movement on the left and the Tea Party
too was born first as outsiders claiming
to be reformers but very quickly became
insiders on the right and even the
Occupy movement which beats born first
as Outsiders on the left surprising
everyone exciting an extraordinary range
of Americans standing for ideas that
Americans hadn't heard articulated in 20
years but they too quickly became aloof
from a political movement demanding and
affecting real change I think that if
these different movements can be brought
about two points in a certain direction
to find a way to speak really for a 99%
and to focus in ways that could make
change possible then these movements
could begin to bring about the recovery
of this Republic , lost that is a plan
now here's the thing we don't know
whether it's even possible for this
democracy to succeed in this it's not
clear we haven't done it in a long time
in a hundred years it's not clear we
have the power but I think what we do
know is how such a plan starts it starts
number one with a certain kind of
clarity it starts with the clarity of
Thoreau it starts with the clarity of
the route Stryker pointing to a common
ground the common ground here is
corruption and getting people to
recognize the common ground from either
side of the political perspective so
pick your issue on the right or the left
and begin to connect it and link them
together so whether it's health care
reform on the left or government
bailouts on the right or global warming
on the left or complex taxes on the
right or financial reform on the left or
financial reform on the right the point
is to get people to recognize there is a
root cause to the systemic
misfiring government and this is its
picture a government focused not upon us
but upon the funders and Route strikers
need to convince and to get we the
people to see this so that we the people
can act in this outsider politics way to
change and second it needs a certain
kind of courage
so as a man Arnold Hyatt very shy guy
this is the biggest picture I could find
of him on the Internet
he was a president of stride right made
great shoes like kids he's also a loyal
Democrat 1996 he was the second largest
contributor to the Democratic Party so
Bill Clinton in 1997 invited him to a
dinner at the Mayflower Hotel with about
30 other fat cats to talk about what
Clinton should do in the remaining years
of his second term each of these
contributors was asked to stand up and
speak we don't have any photographs from
the event but I kind of picture Arnold's
standing and looking something like this
as he addressed the president and he
said this is the president something
like mr. president I know you're an
admirer of Franklin Delano Roosevelt so
I want you to put yourself in
Roosevelt's shoes in 1940 when Roosevelt
recognized that he needed to convince a
reluctant nation to wage a war to save
democracy he said you too mr. president
you too must convince a reluctant nation
to wage a war to save democracy not a
war against fascists but a war against a
certain attitude that comes from us fat
cats an attitude that says merely
because we are rich we are entitled to
direct government policy merely because
we've been successful in the marketplace
we have the right to get the President
on the other end of the phone merely
because we are powerful in one sphere we
you're entitled to be terrible in
another people who have succeeded in
convincing America that democracy
doesn't work now put yourself in Hayate
shoes as he's surrounded by his friends
these fat cats and he's just called
these fat cats out as the problem with
American democracy she can imagine there
was a little bit of silence after he
spoke in that room
the only published account of the
evening said that Clinton's response
effectively slashed Hyatt to pieces
humiliating him in front of the group
now 15 years later it's time we
recognized that Arnold Hyatt was right
it is time we convince a reluctant
nation to wage a war to save democracy
but where Arnold Hyatt was wrong was in
his belief that it would be politicians
that would wage that war it won't be
politicians it'll be citizens it'll be
us it'll be rout strikers I hope it will
be you it is our job it requires our
courage because it's our republic that
we have lost ours and not theirs they
took it away we'd let them let me just
end with one other link so this is an
extraordinary foundation long now but I
want you to recognize the way in which
thinking about the long term is also a
story about recognizing responsibility
so 1989 I'm sure many of you recognize
remember this events when ship under the
command of Captain Joseph Hazelwood ran
aground in Prince William Sound and
spilled about 11 million gallons of oil
into the ocean this is captain Hazelwood
calling in the accident
yeah I'll be back
[Music]
so that way
if you want so you're notified over now
I'm sure many of you asked or asking
yourself the question which was
immediately on everyone's mind after the
accident whether captain Hazelwood was
intoxicated when he was captaining a
super tanker he denied it he said he had
only had four vodkas before he got on
the ship his blood alcohol level said he
must have been at least six times the
legal limit when he got on board but he
and his lawyers fought it there was a
huge litigation around it he was not
absolutely convicted of being
intoxicated at the time he was in charge
so let's say there's some doubt what
there's no doubt about is that he had a
problem with alcohol
his mother testified that he had a
problem with alcohol 1985 four years
before the accident Exxon treated him
for his problem with alcohol 1989 after
the accident the president said he
thought he had mastered his problem but
in 86 he had his driver's license
revoked for a DUI and in 88 the year
before the accident he had had his
driver's license revoked for a DUI at
the time he was captaining a super
tanker he was not allowed to drive a VW
Beetle right now again just forget
though about Hazelwood here what I want
you to do is to think about those around
captain Hazelwood the other officers
people who could have picked up a phone
while a drunk was driving a super tanker
I want you to think about people who did
nothing what do we think about them now
I ask this in this way because as I
think about the problems I've described
tonight I increasingly think that we are
they our nation faces critical problems
requiring serious attention but we have
institutions incapable of that attention
distracted institutions unable to focus
and who is to blame for that
who
is responsible it is too easy to focus
responsibility on the evil people it's
not just the responsibility of the evil
people it's also the responsibility of
the good people the decent people the
people who could have but didn't pick up
a phone it's the responsibility of us we
the most privileged because the most
outrageous part of the problem I've
described tonight is that though these
are corruptions primed by some of the
most privileged they are permitted by
the passivity of the most privileged as
well permitted when Franklin was carried
from the Constitutional Convention in
August 1787 he was stopped by a woman on
the street who asked mr. Franklin what
have you wrought
and Franklin responded a republic madam
if you can keep it a republic a
representative democracy a government
dependent upon the people alone we have
lost that republic and we all have the
responsibility to act to get it back
thank you very much
okay
see
it's
[Applause]
thank you thank you so we've had some
questions come up we're gonna have some
more sure coming up during the during
the talk I'm gonna actually start with
one by Kevin Kelly which is Kevin asked
are there any examples in the rest of
the world of this kind of thing working
yeah so what's hard about comparing our
problems to the rest of the world is the
rest of the world doesn't have the
particular mix of free speech
regulations that we do so other
governments are allowed to limit the
amount of time of a campaign so they can
say a campaign will be a couple months
they're allowed to force television
stations to give free airtime most
mature democracies have robust public
funding systems that are funded into
parties because most of these robust
America democracies are parliamentary
systems as opposed to our kind of mixed
system so there's so many dimensions
along which other countries differ that
it's hard to make a fair comparison but
I think that what's striking is that
there are countries where you have a
government that doesn't spend its time
focused obsessively on this question of
funding campaigns so I was spoke at the
Swedish parliament and was taken out to
dinner by a bunch of members of
parliament including a guy who was a
geek hacker literally I mean that's what
he had done he had hacked and worked on
the gnu/linux and then he became a
member of parliament and he had been
Parliament over Parliament for a camera
was like six or eight years and he said
I literally have never once asked
anybody for money ever you know and you
kind of it was gonna shock of
recognition how could that be possible
match in' a congress filled with people
who didn't ever once have to worry about
that part of their life and instead just
focused on trying to do what they
thought was right and so i think it's
you know we don't have to blame them
well they just had developed a
recognition of the need to protect
against this kind of corrupting
influence and not you know most
democracies haven't and i just think
there are some that have uniquely done
it and and
and we need to file in that case it's
really just a cultural difference or is
a legal difference there's a legal
difference because they fund campaigns
they limits the amount of time for a
campaigns they don't have a need for an
endless campaign and they recognize that
they have to protect the institution
from becoming too dependent on a very
tiny slice of the society and they
succeeded in doing it I think you know
in principle we should be able to do
what the Swedes do in some respects in
some areas of life at least yeah this
would be one okay so how will they ask a
kind of similar question about America
are there examples in history you know
where they've been this kind of
grassroots reform of government yeah
they're history
yeah so exactly 100 years ago the
election of 1912 was an extraordinary
presidential election there were four
candidates Eugene Debs
from the Socialist Left President Taft
Howard Taft who was the stamp at
Republican and then Teddy Roosevelt's
who was running on the bull moose party
and Woodrow Wilson now Roosevelt and
Wilson both called themselves members of
the progressive movement because
progressive back then
didn't mean left-wing progressive was a
conception of the need to repair the
waygu Mott democracy function because
for the prior 15 years journalists had
done an extraordinarily good job in
demonstrating to America that America
was a deeply corrupt democracy and not
corrupt in the kind of subtle ways our
government is corrupt but in the
old-fashioned crude you know let's just
bribed the member of Congress by you
know paying him a hundred dollars of
five thousand dollars or whatever to get
him to do what he wants and America was
so groped out you know so grotesque to
see this and see it in many areas you
know including Upton Sinclair's work
about the way in which that corruption
made it impossible to have safe food and
in the way in which the robber barons
had stolen huge chunks of America as
they built the railroads this eventually
built into a political movement that
demanded change and 70% of Americans
voted for one of these two progressive
candidates so 70 percent of America
united behind changing the system and I
think we in fact began at that movement
a process which did at the federal level
eliminate that kind of crude quid pro
quo corruption again I don't think that
is there are idiots you know the
Blagojevich types the Randy Duke
Cunningham and William Jefferson's but
they are a tiny tiny tiny minority
so we succeeded in eliminating that kind
of corruption but then it morphed it had
to find a way to exert its power it
couldn't do it in the old-fashioned
crude way it now had to do it in a much
more sophisticated way and so it Deval
evolved into this more sophisticated
kind of corruption and the question is
whether we actually have the capacity to
fight that kind of corruption because
when it's just bribery that's just plain
old evil and we as a people are pretty
good at rallying against evil but when
it's the more subtle legal behavior you
know gray area that normal people engage
in decent people engage in it's harder
for us to get angry about it it's harder
for us to do anything about it it might
just be the kind of disease affliction
that we can't actually muster the immune
response to that's the real challenge
here but I do think we succeeded a
hundred years ago and 100 is a good
number 100 speech tonight a hundred
years later we should be able to rallied
again to succeed and and bring about
changes again so in 2019 13 we ratified
two amendments to the Constitution the
first was the 17th amendment which
created the income tax so the robber
barons super-rich would have to bear
their Bert their fair share of the
payment of a cost of government the
second one was eliminating the appointed
Senate because the Senate had become the
focus of corruption as it was simplest
place to buy your influence was to buy a
senator and that senators were appointed
and they became elected after the 17th
after the 17th - 16th amendment and 17th
amendment so the Knights 1913 was a
moment where they celebrated and had
these two progressive amendments
ratified by three-fourths of the states
and and tried to fix the problem they
thought the problem of corruption would
go away it went away for a while in
certain form but returned in this much
more virulent form so there's actually
kind of leads into there's a whole
series of questions that people asked
that kind of are about this the the
money problem is so fundamental won't it
always find ways of kind of getting
around so you know by you know outlawing
a certain kind of public campaign
contribution or certain kind of PAC
you've just sort of put up a wall but
the water goes around it and we've had
lots of questions about that if you know
yes you can say well you can't you can't
have this particular way of corrupting
the system but there's a big force there
that causes corruption and money
fundamentally is power in our system
it's this a constantly changing game is
it yeah so there is no final solution to
this problem and we constantly have to
figure out whether the particular
solution we've embraced still avoids the
kind of corruption we're worried about
the problem though is that for the last
30 years reformers have focused on one
type of solution alone that is the
solution of saying no so they've tried
to limit all sorts of campaign
contributions soft money party money all
sorts of efforts to make it so
corporations can't as as the sole mode
by which reform would be achieved and
when that is the only way in which you
try to achieve reform I think it's
obvious that money is going to try to
find other ways in and will succeed in
finding other ways in that's why it's
essential that we not just think about
limits we also think about supply like
increasing the amount of neutral money
or clean money in the system so that it
no longer makes sense to be beholden to
this special interest money because
you've got enough money in the system
that is not corrupted in this particular
way so you know this is just this is
just a matter of incentives right so
this kind of bizarre counterintuitive
thing about this problem on the one hand
I think most of us believe
this is an impossible problem to solve
um but you look back at the 20th century
and 20th century took on some pretty
hard problems you know fascism beginning
the fight to finally end legalized
racism giving women extraordinary tools
to deal with sexism even conservatives
on this Supreme Court have taken up the
fight against homophobia you know those
are hard problems those are problems
that require generations of work to kind
of tear them out of a social fabric and
remake people so that they are not
racist sexist homophobic century took
them on this is a problem which is just
about changing incentives you know
Connecticut when they changed their
public funding system eighty percent of
elected representatives in the first
year opted into the clean money system
eighty percent why because nobody has a
deep-seated desire to be a vassal to
some Baron it's not like it takes
generations of DNA that makes us into
that it's just they figured out the
simplest way to make money so it raised
money so if we could just change the
incentives I think the problem goes away
so the only the hard part of the problem
is the thing I talked about Jim Cooper
highlighted if all of the insiders have
an interest in preserving the existing
system because they think not just about
government but also life after
government that's the hard part of this
not the crack not be if you have the
right system would we constantly have
the same kind of corruption I think we
could build the right kind of system
that would pretty much avoid the kind of
grotesque debilitating corruption that
we've got right now the current system
must not be much fun if you're a
politician right now I mean it's yeah
it's gotten they must be me
they must not like being vassals yeah
and and I think that's a great
opportunity for reform I mean and again
the thing I described tonight about the
way in which super PACs have taken the
incumbent and placed the incumbent in
the position of Vasil rather than Baron
is an enormous opportunity and if we
could just find a billionaire are there
any billionaires
I've got I got an email today from
somebody who said have you thought about
trying to find a billionaire yeah I did
think about that if we could just get a
billionaire or a couple billionaires to
fund some super PACs that drop a million
dollars into 20 Republican Senate seats
you don't have to win you don't have to
beat them you know it's a kind of
political it's peaceful terrorism right
it's just terrifying them getting them
to wake up to the fact that this is a
system where they no longer control and
that's what's necessary to get them to
begin to think about reform so I am
actually optimistic that the instability
of the current system is going to make
possible this kind of change and what
I'm most concerned about is that we now
focus on the right kind of answer
because there's all sorts of energy out
there about how what we need to do is
reverse Citizens United
and as you heard me say of course we do
need to reverse Citizens United but we
need to remember that on January 20th
2010 the day before citizens united was
decided our democracy was already broken
I mean citizens united might have shot
it but the body was already cold right
so reversing citizens united is
important but it's not going to fix this
democracy and we need much more
aggressive reform than just simply
fixing the mistakes of the Supreme Court
so so actually I'm gonna ask a couple
about mechanisms of reform that people
have suggested John Gilmore you know why
you're down ballot initiatives and he
points out that these are a mechanism
that are put in for sort of grassroots
public reform but you've spoken
disparagingly about them in the past
yeah because I'm so I'm a big believer
in the sovereign once the sovereign
wakes up but I think the sovereign likes
to sleep and most of us you know like to
get on with our life you know we're not
obsessed with power
we don't want to watch everything that's
happening in Sacramento or Washington we
want to raise our kids or have our
hobbies or code or whatever we want to
do things and we don't want to become
experts in what the government should be
doing and there are certain times in our
history where we've got to put those
things down and focus and become the
sovereign and do the right thing and I
think when we focus in the right way I
have total confidence when what we would
do but I think most of the time we're
hopeless at it but wouldn't this be
exactly the kind of thing where a ballot
initiative might be useful where it's
not us getting involved in government
it's okay the game so in reforming
government right so if so if John's
question is why don't I like ballot
initiatives because I lived in
California for nine years and saw what
happened right but that's different from
saying I don't support the idea of
people exercising the power to take back
control over this government and fix it
of course I do now it turns out that our
Constitution does not permit ballot
initiatives to be used to force
amendments inside system so ballot
initiatives couldn't actually force the
amendment but ballot initiatives could
be very effective in forcing state
legislatures to do the right thing
either in ratifying an amendment or in
the other path which I didn't talk about
more which I think is essential calling
for a constitutional convention that
could propose the amendments that
Congress would never on its own proposed
so it's part of this problem that just
the federal government has become too
attractive a target as I mean if you've
got one-stop shopping for all your
special interest needs yeah yeah I you
know so this is where the libertarians
are onto something I'm not a libertarian
I used to be I grew up but I used to be
a libertarian
but but where they're on to something is
is you know as Richard Epstein from
Chicago would put it when you've got
such a powerful government that's doing
so much it's a constant honey jar honey
pot you know for people who are
interested in trying to find ways to
leverage their privilege into special
benefits for themselves and there's all
sorts of fantastic data coming out now
because transparency about what
lobbyists do is being used by political
scientists to make a tight connection
between the amount of money spent on
lobbying and the actual return and the
return from lobbying is in the tens of
thousands percent for many of these
provisions and so you know you're a CEO
of some company and your lobbyist comes
to you and says I can guarantee you
three hundred percent return on this
particular investment and your actual
inventors say you know maybe 40 on what
we're doing you as a CEO are gonna
invest more and more in your of your
money in the lobbying game as opposed to
in the widget inventing game and that's
a real problem but I think with a lot
where the libertarians go wrong is just
kind of assuming away the problem so the
libertarians say you know Ron Paul says
so the solution here is just to get
small government reminds me of remember
the Steve Martin Joe Christie part and
say so here's how you can get a million
dollars in pay no taxes first get a
million dollars you know and so so
that's the libertarians point sure if we
could get a smaller government then we
wouldn't have to worry about but the
point is if a large government benefits
fundraising makes easier to fundraise if
complicated taxes makes it easier to
fundraise then how are you ever gonna
get small government and simple taxes
when the very people who need to enact
those changes would never enact those
changes because it would make the job of
raising money for their campaigns ten
thousand times more difficult so you've
got to address the incentives of the
congressmen before we get to the
question you know that they want to ask
which is what's the size or scope or
reach of government if you want that
question to be answered
level pine forest so let me answer your
rhetorical question I mean there for
example their state governments that
would like to have power that the
federal government has and they have the
right to pass the constitutional
amendment yeah and so there's a big push
among states to try to reclaim the right
to appoint the senator because if the
states controlled one house in Congress
and the states could protect themselves
more effectively against the federal
government yeah so I and these you know
you go on this is the stuff I do for a
real living you know I'm a
constitutional law professor it's
endlessly complicated interesting junk
but I think that all of that is you know
secondary to the primary problem so I
what I'm talking about is what whether
you think that reform is necessary or
not what is the sequence of reform we
need like what is the first change
because I I really think until we get
this problem solved there's no other
problem we're gonna be able to solve
yeah but I guess the the argument would
be that you know the money going to
where the power is is a symptom of of
the centralization power yeah so it
might even be a deeper root it might be
a deeper root but again and I'm I mean
I'm conceding the roof but then the
question is do you actually have a means
to attacking that root right so I'm
trying to solve the first thing that
gives us this means so Vint Cerf ass
would turn woman's help so I also I used
to be a believer in term limits and then
lived in California you know and I think
that the the problem with term limits is
that I think in Sacramento the only
people who know how to do anything are
the lobbyists because everybody else is
a kind of amateur who's just kind of you
know working their way through and and
that you know the problem in government
is not their genuine public servant who
wants to spend a career in government
you know Tom Lantos was my congressman
here who you know was a foreign-born
American so he was never gonna be
President he was not there for anything
other than just serving and he served
for a long time and and that kind of
public service is something I think
which is not the problem I think the
problem is when they are focused
the way that they can leverage public
service into private benefit or they are
focused on ways to leverage public
benefit to make it possible to get
reelected so if we solve that problem I
wouldn't have any problem with people
serving as long as the people elect them
now there are people out there who say
well let's do a deal let's say term
limits plus campaign finance reform and
I kind of you know I kind of think maybe
unnecessary but I'm happy to strike any
deal that gets us to public funding but
I don't think that actually the problem
is the terms I think the problem is the
funding so you also identified another
problem there which is the complexity of
the system and you know there is a sort
of fundamental information asymmetry in
sort of special interest issues which is
that the special interest has the
capacity to track the details of all the
legislative votes and amendments and
things like that on their special
interests whereas the rest of us can't
possibly attract I mean even most most
members of Congress can't really track
all of that detail and they really even
their staff we can't track it so they
end up actually just focusing on their
issues and and so is is there anything
we could do about you know that that's
sort of fun to make we there there's a
lot of but I guess there's kind of a
culture of transparency these days that
sort of suggests that more information
more exposure of information and sort of
fundamentally good and I wonder if you
subscribe to that kalt or not yeah so
I'm I I went through a really serious
self-destructive stage just after I left
California I think it was related I
didn't realize this was gonna get so
poor yeah well I'd you you primed it um
where I wrote three articles they kind
of alienated me from all of my friends
so one of them was an article that was
originally going to be titled the
tyranny of tiny minds it was an attack
on the Obama administration the second
was an article about it's called a love
of culture it was critical of Google and
there are books search settlement and
the third was an article titled against
transparency so all of my transparency
friends were like outraged that I could
write something against transparency and
I
my shrink and I have worked out what
caused all of that but but there is
there was actually something I think
there is something to think about with
the transparency point no you know the
sort of thing that Tim O'Reilly does or
the sort of thing that you know
government transparency people are doing
that's trying to get all the government
data we can out there and machine
readable form so people can do all sorts
of stuff with it that is unambiguously
good in my view but what I'm skeptical
of is people who believe that we solve
the problem I'm talking about merely by
making everything transparent you know
so I serve on map lights board map
lights fantastic organization building
all sorts of great tools to track the
relationship between money and results
to make it trivially easy for everybody
to see this connection and of course I
think that's good and importantly but we
also have to recognize the consequence
of that the consequence of that is just
to prove to people what they already
believed which is money buys results in
Congress and if all you're trying to do
is to make it clearer that money drive
bias results in Congress then you forget
you forget the central San Francisco
slogan you got to give them hope right
you got to give them hope right if
they're convinced that the system is
corrupted then they're just gonna stay
home and play with their kids or do
whatever else they can do so that's why
you've got a tie transparency to some
real reform right so you know with the
Deepwater Horizon of course it was a
great thing that there was a webcam
underwater showing us the muck spewing
into the Gulf but it's just a confusion
to think that that's all we wanted was a
webcam like a high-def webcam seeing
this you know what we wanted is the
sludge to stop spewing into the Gulf and
that's the same thing here we want
transparency so that we can get a clean
system of government so um Rania Cohen
is has asked you to please mention
something about the California clean
money campaign yeah so there's been a
campaign for a long time that should
have been much more successful not
because of people's not hard work but
there's very powerful interests that are
blocking it
that has tried in a stepwise to pick
particular offices they are likely to
succeed and try to get those things
passed first as a way to set an example
for others and and I've supported I
think that's extremely important and I
you know and and anything that happens
locally you know so for example in San
Francisco there was a very effective
clean money project that then Ben had
funding issues at least when I was last
year these are important issues to fight
locally to get this pushed and and to
succeed but I actually think that it's
much more important to recognize we have
to fight this in more than one forum at
the same time we clean money locally we
need clean money nationally and the
national one might ultimately be
essential to solve to be able to get it
everywhere else because most people
don't actually have a clear sense of
what happens locally for a lot of issues
I mean really locally they do but a lot
of the stuff that gets regulated in the
state level is obscure to people what
they see at the federal level is
constant and they're constantly
disappointed with what happens at the
federal level so we have to find
someplace to build trust and I and and
so I think that it's a it's really
important not to kind of wait till we
fix all the states and then fix the
federal government we have to be able to
walk and chew gum here at the same time
well I'm gonna end on a question from
Joseph Brenner who basically asked if
there's some advantage that we could
have over the short term thinking
political forces by thinking long term
on this I mean if we're willing to
optimize you know beyond the current
term of politicians is there some way we
can sort of take advantage of their sort
of short-term tendency and because after
all what we're interested in is a long
term reform yeah so what I've always
found wonderful and kind of puzzling
about long term thinking is that at the
scale that you know this foundation is
thinking about it it's for each of us
completely irrational you know we're all
gonna be dead
so why are we wasting our time and and
there is something linked that links the
project I'm talking about in that kind
of irrationality I write about it at the
end of my book you know so I was in
Dartmouth and a woman stood up after I
spoke and she said to me okay you've
absolutely convinced me there is no hope
there's nothing we can do and when she
said that I had this kind of shock flash
wreck thought in my head so I imagined a
doctor saying to me your your son has
terminal brain cancer and there's
nothing you can do and I thought would I
do nothing and you know when you think
about it like that you recognize the way
in which we in many contexts act against
the irrational or act in the face of the
irrational and love is one of those
places where even if it's completely
hopeless
you do whatever the hell you can even if
you're convinced it's hopeless you do
whatever the hell you can that's what it
means to love your son that's what it
means to love your country you know
there people go off and fight wars on
crazier theories about supporting
democracy than anything I've spoken
about tonight they risk their life for
love of country and I think that you
know when you hear this when you feel
the impossibility of this issue like
when you feel the impossibility of
really thinking about the 10,000 year
horizon
you've got to access that part in each
of us which knows that the rational
calculation is not the only reason we do
things we humans do things is what
corporations do but this is why
corporations are not us we do things we
celebrate do
that are plainly irrational loving our
children loving our country loving our
planet even though we'll never see any
of those things come to the perfection
we imagine them to be
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]